there's a new poll out nationally of hypothetical
match-ups against Donald Trump.
The poll is from Quinnipiac university and
it shows that Donald Trump is behind every
single one of the six democratic contenders
that pull, uh, takers were asked about or
not poll takers.
I guess people poll the poll takers, I guess
where the pollsters, people who were polled,
uh, in all six instances chose the democratic
challenger over Donald Trump.
Now we're going to look at this, but I want
to say right now, I wish they had included
some other candidates in these hypothetical
match-ups.
And I'll tell you why in a moment.
But let's look at the numbers first.
Biden vs Trump.
Trump is nine points behind Biden, Sanders
versus Trump.
Trump is eight points behind Bernie.
Uh, Trump is seven points behind Elizabeth
Warren, six points behind Michael Bloomberg,
five points behind Pete, Buddha, judge, and
four points behind Amy Klobuchar.
So as you can see, these are national numbers.
Now, a few thoughts about this.
Number one.
I would love to have seen hypothetical match-ups
against Andrew Yang and tool C Gabard because
they're supporters already.
They call into me all the time and they say,
David, the the candidacies of Andrew Yang
and Tulsi are being suppressed and they will
also often say that their candidate yang supporters
say this about yang tools to support her say
this about tool C, they will say, the only
person who can really beat Trump is my candidate,
be it yang or tool C. clearly according to
this latest poll, it's not the case that those
would be the only people who can beat Trump,
but it would be great to see Andrew Yang in
a hypothetical head to head against Donald
Trump.
Same with toolset.
Now my prediction is especially because of
name recognition, I don't think that in a
hypothetical matchup right now, yang or tool
C do as well against Trump as Biden, Bernie
and Warren.
I don't.
I just don't think that would be the case,
but as long as they're not included in the
polls, we don't know and it gives fuel to
their followers to continue to say they are
actually the strongest ones to face off against
Trump, but their candidacies are being suppressed.
Look, case in point, their names aren't even
being brought up now, again, because of name
recognition, it's possible that you would
have a huge number of undecided if you pulled
that way or that the numbers wouldn't be favorable
to yang and tools to respectively, but I still
think that it should be done.
Now let's get to the caveats and the problems
with this type of polling.
Number one, our election is really 50 smaller
elections.
This is an electoral election, not a national
popular vote.
We haven't had a presidential election where
we end up with a nine point gap on the popular
vote or an eight point gap or seven or even
six, five in a really, really long time.
Most likely the 2020 election popular vote
is not going to be decided by you.
You know, six points, seven points.
It's going to be much, much closer than that.
It's going to tighten when it tightens.
The race is going to be about key States that
are different makers.
What I mean by that is a huge margin in California
for the democratic candidate in the popular
vote is not going to help you win if you can't
win key States like some combination of Pennsylvania,
North Carolina, Michigan, Wisconsin, Florida,
Ohio, so on and so forth.
Now of course, if the democratic candidate
wins by nine in the popular vote, they are
going to win a lot of those key States by
default because the the 50 elections are individual
elections, but they also are related in terms
of the mood of the country and the general
momentum, but that is really the way we need
to be interpreting these hypothetical match-ups.
While these hypothetical match-ups do give
us a lot of important information about momentum
and the mood of the country and favor ability
and skepticism of Trump, rightfully so.
If you see Biden plus nine and Bernie plus
eight and you think this is in the bag very,
very far from it.
The other important thing to keep in mind
when you look at a lot of these match-ups,
for example, Biden versus Trump, 51 to 42
that's 93% of the vote.
That means that there is another 7% that as
of right now are either undecided, unsure,
or voting for somebody else.
That 7% alone, even without Joe Biden losing
any support, like imagine that in that 51
to 42 matchup, Biden gets the 51 but the seven
that is right now undecided goes to Trump.
So it's 51 Biden, 49 Trump, Trump lost by
almost three percentage points in 2016 and
popular vote wise, but one electorally.
That's why it's really important not to read
more into these numbers then make sense.
Even, you know for people who say burn, you
can beat Trump.
Bernie's up by eight 51 to 43 that's 94% of
the vote.
There's another 6% there which could go to
Trump.
So it's really important not to get any false
sense of complacency because of these polls.
We should not be lulled by these results.
And especially when you look at what happened
in 2016 when you look at Wisconsin, Pennsylvania,
Michigan, for example, being the difference
makers in North Carolina.
Now I'm confusing myself, but I think you
know, the point that I'm making, um, it is
really important that our plan B not just
get out the vote generally because you know,
California Trump's going to get crushed in
the popular vote margin will be huge.
But either way, whether you win California
by one, two or 10, you just get California's
electoral votes.
These key States are where we need to be focusing
on, get out the vote and when the eventual
democratic nominee is decided, I hope that
they actually will do that.
Let me know what you think about the hypothetical
match-ups.
Let me know if you agree, disagree that Andrew
Yang and Tulsi should be included just so
we can get the numbers because their followers
insist that they are really the ones that
can defeat Donald Trump.
And in the meantime, we will continue covering
this on the David Pakman show Instagram page
at David Pakman show.
And while you are there, I asked you to also
humbly follow me,
be
on Instagram at
David
dot
package